я у всіх матері питання ти дивись де ти
як стріляти в нього чи оля нова чи новий
на правій нозі та савченко на
irfa його то Олександрова стала справжньою
сенсацію з родив і причому він і
краще в Україні
у Європі там rx і низько європейських
політиків ж вислужив оскарженню вигляд
тпр обмін за 3 мани мем нас не до
конфлікту на донбасі та при швидкості вона
в 1 годину нагадав і до провалювання лиша
обміну в я знімай за малу
сподіваюся картинку на їжу на незаконну
azn вона в Росії українка
мінські виводи запрошують обмін по місяці
нами і цілу годину таємниця цеху ось важливі
тільки а біржа частими я копаю я за на з
санкціями проти Росії з частими на що
при два чаї видно у мене контроль над
кордоном при б на нього в не
адже виженуть бої та висновки не російських
солдатів з донбасу
1000 до досягнення компромісу дали
купить варджеки експерти і вимагаючи
видно незабаром так званих днр і лнр взводи
нападу поліцейської місії обидва
руси їж і так дзвони сепаратисти
домагається виду України рухай на
проведення виборі на вухо полонених
обраним конфліктом на територіях я на
борту поки що можна владу організувати
та вибори на донбасі за стандартами все
поки там пара бувають весь каємось і
вкрай поки там не може болотова тася
української партії і в ситуації куне
вилийте проблем з безкоштовно на думку
міжнародних зали прання в нато великі
шанси на успіх за право чині
поліцейської місії на донбасі приклади
абхазії то придністров'я може за
свічки який сценарій russia's проби і
троянди град і на донбасі виварити місяця в
одну годину самуї москва зламів
заморожена конфлікту обидва подання позову
латинос ході україни до даллес меншу
всі шанси на скошування санкту так не
нього ферді ваш шматок солод та фінансові
санкції проти Росії doc його на ни
висновки свої whiskas донбасу
та на power на україні контроль над
кордоном
обидва на вигляд краю місії доступ до
всієї окупованої території віджатися
перед машину мінськими водами і все ж
Пташник експерти в труднощі
мінського процесу в Європі одягаєте
ще один савченко таки з приємним і
при незабаром мирного врегулювання на
донбасі